اول شيء لازم نعرف معلومه كل الشركات
التقنيه في الايام الماضيه قامت بفصل عدد
كبير من الموظفين فيسبوك ترى صرت اكثر من
11,000 موظف همم شركات كثيره مشت في قرار
فصل موظفين من عندهم وهذا ترى شيء مو جديد
على شركات التقنيه او الشركات بشكل عام
لان كل الشركات التقنيه خلال السنوات
الماضيه نمت نموم مضطره جدا كبير
وللمعلوميه قرار فصل الموظفين ترى اللي
اعتذر عنه رئيس دوله السابق لانه طلع في
تغريده تكلم قال انا اتحمل جزء من مسؤوليه
فصل الموظفين نحن نظفنا اعداد كبيره جدا
الموظفين في تويتر
رؤى انه ممكن يحققون ارباح معينه في ذلك
جاء بعده موظفين فالشغل اللي خلصها شخص
صار يخلص شخصيه وهذا ساهم بشكل جديد جدا
كبير في زياده اعداد الموظفين بشكل جدا
كبير وتقليل كفاءه همم العمل في داخل شركه
لانه همم عدد الموظفين جدا كبير فاللي
قادر يشتغل يشتغل واللي يشوف انه 7,500
عدد كبير عدد تويتر منصه اجتماعيه تمام
فيها شغلات جدا بسيطه مين مو مثل الفيسبوك
اللي هي همم على قولتهم نقدر نقول انها
مجموعه فيها عده تطبيقات تحت هذه المنصه
وبداخله في عالم الموظفين تقريبا فيها
اكثر من خمسه
و80,000 موظف الا لما اكون همم في الرقم
تقريبا لكن
تقريبا 11,000 فلذلك موضوع فصل الموظفين
والاستغناء عنهم غيره هذا شيء صاير خلال
السنه الماضيه او خلال الاشهر الماضيه همم
وللمعلوميه همم هذا بسبب يعني على قولتهم
قرارات جدا كثيره كانت في سنوات الماضيه
اول نتكلم احنا يعني تضخم الاوضاع
الاعلاميه وغيرها فهمم
اغلب الشركات في منصات التواصل اجتماعيه
قللت الصرف الاعلاني او لم تصرف كما كانت
تصرف ثلاث سنوات الماضيه بسبب المشاكل
اللي كانت موجوده وبسبب امور مختلفه فلذلك
الصرف قل ومدخولات من الصلاه التواصل
اجتماعيه بشكل مباشر يكون ترا من
الاعلانات اللي تقدمها الشركات فاذا
الشركات ما اعلنت ولا صوت اعلانات داخل
منصات التواصل اجتماعيه ما في مدخول لان
من الصلاه التواصل اجتماعيه مجانيه
فالمستخدم والاعلانات هم همم مصدر الدخل
الاول من الصلاه نفسها